[Music]
so anthony you have spoken now
all over america many many times and
certainly on this show many times
about this idea of how to pay for
college
paying cash for college is college
still a good idea all of these kinds of
things
because of this ridiculous epic student
loan
debacle that our idiot congress
continues to fund
with your money and my money and it's an
obvious failure
it's an obvious blight on the american
people and yet they continue to do this
to the american people
uh and yet walk around talk about
forgiving loans but keep making them
right right so uh something's wrong with
that but you know this idea of paying
for kids college
it's something that families that are
building wealth
always want to look at yeah yeah and
here's here's the reason why dave
is because it's preventing
our families from actually building
wealth
if they are racking up student loan debt
prime example uh the average student
would graduate about 38 000
student loan debt but then dave when we
go deeper a fifth of these young people
will graduate with a hundred thousand
two hundred thousand dollars
or more in student loan debt so a recent
survey came out and found out that
when these young people graduate they're
going back home and 31
of them uh delay moving out of their
parents house because they have student
loan debt
that's one-third that's one-third of our
young people
are not living adult lives are not
living adult lives and your mama's
basement is not an adult life
but you went to college to become an
adult to have it well he's part of
becoming an adult you are
becoming one whether you wanted to or
not yeah that's how this what you signed
up for called staying alive
and here's when that bothered me dave is
less than one-third
of these young people delay getting
married because of student loans
about 20 percent of them are saying that
right yes sir yes sir one out of five
one out of five and this is why we have
babysit five
this is why i wrote the book debt free
degree
because you have these young people
going to college to go after the
american dream you have these young
people going to college
so they can go out there and pursue
everything that they want but it's the
debt that's delaying them from getting
there
and what we got to do up front is start
educating our young people
and really dave i'm going to say this
i'm going to say this we're not really
just educating we got to ask the
question
is college the right path for your child
and it may or may not be bottom line but
if it is
here's how you get into it 100 debt free
well we're not against education not at
all education is a good thing
absolutely uh sometimes becoming an
educated uh
welder makes you 85 000 a year and
you're one year out of high school
and you have four years to earn while
someone else is going to school earning
nothing
so you are you know you're 250 000 ahead
before we start the equation um but and
so and getting an education in
left-handed puppetry as rachel says
is a dumb idea and people go get these
useless degrees
and act like that somehow society owes
them something so we're not talking
about that
but we are talking about getting a good
solid academic underpinning
to be able to advance your cause the
cause of your life
yes and that's a fine thing and you can
do that at a state university
with a basic good solid degree
that gets you a job
you know uh supply chain people coming
out
logistics right now making 80 grand with
an undergrad
i mean so you know you do not you know
you obviously can go through and get an
accounting degree obviously you can go
through and get a communications degree
obviously you can get a marketing degree
there's a lot of business stuff you can
do on one side on the other side there's
other
specialty things engineering
architecture there's all kinds of
degrees that are worth the money
if you don't pay some crazy but
ivy league price for it you can get your
money back it is a good
investment yes but all education is not
an investment some of it's stupid yeah
absolutely and my my question is what's
the roi
if you go to this school if you get this
degree can you get a job
will it be a good return on your four
years and the money that you spent
so when i started teaching this stuff 30
years ago we would interview people and
a survey would tell us 98
of parents are planning for their kids
to go to school
okay seven percent were saving
for their kids to go to school so in
other words all talk
no do big hat no cattle right
big discussion no actual getting ready
to send them so i mean i guess you
didn't have a plan how you consumed
school
maybe government welfare was the problem
or or dave did they
did they not save or were they planning
on just taking this they just talked
in their head it was a good idea until
they went to the pizza place and spent
this week's paycheck
you know or until they needed to go to
the dadgum all-inclusive whatever
at cancun yeah and uh all of a sudden
kids college takes a back seat because
they weren't budgeting for it they
weren't actually freaking doing it they
were discussing it
nowadays it's shifted and there's
actually of the people that say that
they think they should be saving a high
percentage are actually doing something
yes
so saving at baby step five you know
four five and six we teach you to do
together you're out of debt you have
your emergency fund you're putting money
into retirement it's four
kids college is five meaning saving
investing for kids college yes
that's important yeah but dad and i want
to say this because you said four five
six and seven is all
done at the same time we are not saying
sacrifice your retirement no i said 15
of your income exactly into retirement i
just want to make sure people then you
move on to baby step five
four is fir before five yes that's yeah
you'll learn that in college
four is first you put 15 of your income
into retirement
and then five you do kids college yeah
and then six you with any
other money you can find you pay off the
house early right right and this is what
millionaires are doing
baby step millionaires the everyday
millionaires that we're talking to all
the time
this is how they're living it's what
they're doing and then if they're if
they got the 529 full and that
particular kid doesn't go to school or
they get a bunch of scholarships
you can move that money around you can
do different stuff with it you're not
stuck
but you are stuck if you're broke and
here's what millionaires are not doing
they're not taking out parent plus loans
they're not allowing their kids to go
out there and sign for student loans
they're saying no this is what you're
going to do and if you want me to pay
for if you want me to help you with it
then you're going to a local community
college you're going to a local end
state
but we're not signing for any loans why
because i love you
don't allow your your child to make a
child decision a kid decision to
an adult choice no no don't do it yeah
you don't get to decide
because that's where uh my girlfriend
goes oh lord this is not how you pick a
college
it's um but people do yeah they do
people do
and a lot of them one girl called you
and i are here on the air a few months
ago and she's like
i want to go to so and so because the
town is pretty
shoot me i was laughing at that one dave
one of them said i want to go to this
college because my boyfriend is going
there
yeah i just wanted to scream yeah it's
the same thing
and so yeah moms and dads you have to be
good parents
and teach them how to go to school where
they can afford it where you can pay
cash for it
you need to save money so that you can
cause all of this to happen
in your college 529's get in touch with
one of our smartmister pros and you can
get that done
guys this is very doable but you just
have to start actually
thinking about it and doing something
about it it's very doable
debt-free degree is the book yes by
anthony o'neill
this is the ramsay show